what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to lil
loaded gang unit this video was sent to
me on my instagram
so if you guys have any clips that you
want me to react to make sure you send
it to me on instagram
while you're at it do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily
videos okay
and by the way my instagram is in the
description of this video so if you guys
have a video that you want to request
all you have to do is
send it i check all my messages
[Music]
hey this is a very low budget
low budget video shoot already
i i can just tell not
hey hey dance to this [ __ ] if you gang
bang
oh i hate how catchy this is i'm already
like bopping my shoulders i can feel it
i'm being the same
thing to this [ __ ] if you gang bang
give a [ __ ]
okay dance to this [ __ ]
if you're gang so what he's trying to
say is like
if you're a part of his gang right you
dance to this
and like i'm not even gonna lie this
shit's catching that's all these [ __ ]
[Music]
that's like a gang right that's it's
like crips versus
blood i think glock's with a stitch i
might gotta see me in
okay so he's saying that the people in
his game like in the crypt gang
they got us back so if there's like
let's say he gets into like
a disagreement with someone right
they're gonna come in and they have his
back
pull up with that fire i'm a real ass
shooter [ __ ] i don't wanna drown
hey okay so he oh my gosh so he's saying
like
he doesn't drive because he's the guy
that shoots
and like drive-bys
i mean that's one way to get out of
driving i know
some people
i'm not going to say names but i know
some people
that get out of driving in other ways
but
i'm not going to say names to this [ __ ]
if you gang
bang on give a [ __ ] it will be the same
[Music]
oh that's clever these guys
are berry berry sweet like some pie
that's clever i wonder what kind of pie
i just like hey i got a beam on the end
you can't hide
he
okay so he said he's not a soldier
he's a hoe in disguise so
what that means is like this guy's like
trying to act tough like he's trying to
act like
he knows like what he's doing
right and like he's just like hard
whatever
but he's really a hoe like he's a [ __ ]
he can't do [ __ ]
so he's calling him out
i hate how catchy this song is oh my
gosh like i'm shimmy don't mind just
gonna get fried
slim [ __ ]
[Music]
so he said he likes his girls thin
lately we've had a lot of love for like
big girls in the media right you always
say like
little dicky song and like you know body
positivity but he's saying
f that i like my girls small to this
[ __ ] if you gang
bang on give a [ __ ] one bang the same
thing dance to this [ __ ] if you gang
bang on give a [ __ ] if we don't bang the
same damn
catch is how
[Music]
[Music]
all right here are my final thoughts so
it definitely catchy i was dancing and
shimmying the whole time like
i can't deny that thought number two low
budget
i could just the music video
it was low budget i you can't
i can't like deny that like it looked
like something that i could have shot on
my iphone
i'm just i'm just being honest um three
he believes heavily in like the gang
he's in so
i think it was the crips right
he thinks highly of them like honestly
he's he's letting you guys know
that they have his back so on a scale of
one to five
i'm gonna give this a four um i
really enjoyed how catchy the song was
and i felt like i could dance to the set
parties
i can't relate to anything in the song
like at all
but you know i'm just trying to judge it
based on like how much i dance and stuff
so
let me know in the comments if you agree
with this rating and if you don't let me
know in the comments what rating you
would give the song
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification
bell and i will talk to you guys next
time